minnie luke knock it off no one thinks
it's funny
are you talking to us huh
hey as long as everybody's just sitting
around oh oh they're gonna do another
one ah thank you santa claus that's
hilarious hope you're having fun cause
that's about to end okay stick to the
scripted patter sweetie all right and
one and two
silent
oh my god what was that i'm sure it's
fine
here we go again
that is your daughter screaming
lily are you okay the forgotten boy i
hurt him he's in there all right of
course let's get him out we'll make sure
that he doesn't bother oh god oh god
andy take off the blazer
i have so many questions boys lily go
play where snow would be so is this a
thing is the first time yeah no auntie
i'm sick of the lies
we've been having improper relations
aren't you engaged oh suddenly you're
concerned about loyalty oh you're
talking to me won't that bore you
apparently i'm boring listen everyone
let's not let this ruin our beautiful
holiday alex nobody needs your sarcasm
right now it's ugly honey this is andy
and haley's private business i think we
should be focused on this special night
this special silent night one in two
minutes so
nice guys i have a surprise
is bad
oh my god
this is one of my christmas surprises
andy you can spend christmas with your
fiance after all
hi little battle hey pumpkin beth you
mind if i have a quick chit chat with
your man yeah i'll give beth a tour of
the house while we get gloria up to
speed don't you just love the holidays
full of wonder and magic and surprise
what
sit
mr dumpy it's not your turn to talk
that's my daughter and you're engaged to
someone else if this is a fling it's
over you understand me
but if this is something real you need
to be honest with beth it's time to step
up and be a man
i understand let me tell you something
life is like a mountain road with a new
adventure around every corner
wow right did you just think of that i
did
[Music]
seems tense
your big sis is kind of a disaster huh
fave we are a lot alike like you said
and sometimes we can give off a negative
vibe without meaning to what's your
point well i was thinking maybe we could
make more of an effort to be more
positive and actually enjoy christmas as
a goof
okay all right new plan we wait until
the whole haley andy thing
blows over everyone gets a little
liquored up other people and then right
before dessert you sit down at the piano
what the hell is that
[Music]
son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
that's it i'm drinking
[Music]
[Applause]
that's gotta hurt
[Music]
you